the state wrestling champion
championship in Texas just wrapped up
for the second year in a row the women's
class six a hundred and ten pound
division was won by Mack begs Mack
that's right although biologically
female Mack is transitioning to male and
as part of that transition takes
testosterone and steroids but max still
competes as a girl because Texas rules
require school athletes to compete as
the gender on their birth certificate if
that's not confusing enough well it is
and that's why we asked mark Stein to
come and join us to explain it so mark
this seems like I think it's worth being
paranoid about every new development
because they they always are slippery
slope actually despite claims the
country right but why is girls sports
not over boys have a massive physical
biological advantage in a lot of sports
and if you allow boys to compete as
girls then what happens to girls well
there is no girls sports then but
you'reyou're right just to go back to
what you said Tucker this may seem
trivial and the slippery slope it isn't
actually I would say this is actually
one of the biggest stories of our time
perhaps the biggest bigger than the
budget deficit or whatever you use the
word gender in the introduction in my
day we used to talk about the sexes and
when I was a school boy it would say
name date of birth place of birth sex
and every errant schoolboy would put sex
yes please and with a standard schoolboy
joke and we all tittered and all the
girls put sexes female and that was how
it was divided and somewhere along the
way the word sex the two sexes were
abolished and replaced by the word
gender and in the course that we lost
not just a great schoolboy joke but in a
sense we lost that clear distinction and
so we have replaced the two biological
sexes with a multiplicity of genders and
the abolition of the sexes is in fact
not a small thing and this and the point
of this wrestling competition Texas has
responded to some of these modish
fancies by saying no
biological girls can compete in girls
sports and biological boys and this is a
way of just saying well whatever you do
whatever laws you pass to protect
traditional sex roles and girls sports
and boys sports we're going to ride a
coach and horses through it anyway and
you're done and it's over it is one of
the biggest stories about well I agree
with that and I think it has profound
it's what we always do the story not for
any print reason but because the way
that men and women get along is the
basis of society and it's nothing's more
important than that but I'm fascinated
by the idea that a small group of people
can determine what the rest of us are
allowed to say out loud about even
biology we're now required to lie about
biology and were punished if we don't
and how did that happen no one really
believes this only butty people do and
they're in control how well I think
that's what that's the other fascinating
thing you know when if you're a climate
skeptic then the left demonize you and
say you're anti science but we are
actually abolishing biology in a lot of
this I mean what I find interesting
about this is as you say there's there's
only you say there's only eight people
who actually believe all this however
many people believe it they're the
people who matter in the United States
and in Canada and Europe and every other
advanced society so for example if I
were to miss gender miss gender this
girl who's transitioning into a boy
there would be a Twitter storm about how
I'd miss gendered him or her and and
that was disgraceful and celebrities get
hounded into apologizing profusely for
this the fact is this girl transitioning
into a boy is on drugs that increase her
strength and has just ruined the girls
state championship for all the undrugged
unstated girl wrestlers and and what I
particularly resent about this story
Tucker is the loss of seemed leanness in
our society if somebody wants to
transition into a boy or transition into
a girl great
but maybe that means you have to give up
the wrestling that you can of everything
that you should take up the violin
instead not wreck a sport not wreck a
statewide sport for all the other
participants steep and true mark Stein
thank you as always for that it was
great thanks a lot Tucker